in Beijing on Sunday the most important
political meeting in a generation began
every five years the Communist Party
holds a National Congress and they
choose their top leaders as by far the
most powerful body that really controls
the whole country at this Congress Xi
Jinping is getting another five years as
party boss and head of the military and
perhaps even longer
I'm David Rennie I'm The Economist of
Aging bureau chief and I was one of very
few foreign journalists allowed to
attend yeah
my journey to the party Congress
actually started two days earlier
Saturday morning and I am on my second
day of quarantine in uh what's
technically called a closed-loop
management uh quarantine hotels you can
see that there's fences uh temporary
fences all around this hotel we have
guards we all have to have badges that's
my
Communist Party Congress badge
and on Sunday morning we drove through
Beijing in a motorcade of coaches with a
police car at the front into the Great
Hall of the people it's a giant Palace
of sort of communist 1950s architecture
and it's a really old-fashioned piece of
communist theater you could be in
Stalin's Moscow you could be in chairman
Mars Beijing of 50 or 60 years ago
in case you're in any diet as to who is
the star of this show
and every single of these displays has a
picture of the parsley leader Xi Jinping
we went into the Great Wall of the
people and sat up in the Press Gallery
next to the military band and we watched
Xi Jinping give his work aboard the last
five years
[Music]
[Applause]
there are a ton of headwinds uh really
battering the Chinese economy and really
XI jinping's claims to be a competent
Governor you know we have the Chinese
public who are very tired of some of
these zero covet restrictions one in
five young Chinese is unemployed at the
moment there's a housing crisis looming
and so the outside world might expect a
speech from Xi Jinping which addresses
those concerns that is not our work
report to a Communist Party Congress
goes down this was an extraordinarily
confident speech note we also signals of
a change of course at all
the biggest and loudest applause was for
some remarks about Taiwan
yeah
yeah
it could have been worse if you are the
Taiwanese government if you are taiwan's
allies in places like Washington you
were worried that there might be
something that was much more like a
deadline a sign of impatience or urgency
and there wasn't actually a Taiwan
language didn't change
the Posse Congress lasts until next
Saturday and there is some business to
do there is a report from The Fearsome
discipline inspector which basically is
the body that catches corrupt officials
and purges uh XI jinping's enemies uh
their leadership will be chosen the
party Constitution we know is going to
be amended and that will be a signal
about just how much personal Authority
Xi Jinping is going to claim so at the
moment the party Constitution Praises Xi
Jinping thought on socialism with
Chinese characteristics for a new era
it's a mouthful if that is shortened to
just cheating things thought that will
put him on a par with Chairman Mao
because Mount zidong thought is the only
other form of ideology that is
identified as snappily that may sound
ridiculously Arcane but that is actually
how the Communist Party signals giant
power struggles and power moves
if you're a viewer at home try to work
out if Xi Jinping plans to rule for
another five years maybe 10 maybe for
life then you need to look at the line
of men in suits who will follow him out
onto stage and we think on Sunday he
will be the new standing committee and
if everyone in that lineup is either too
old or too young to be a plausible
successor in five years time then you
will know that China's supreme leader
does not plan on giving up power anytime
soon
thank you for watching to read all of
our coverage of the 20th party Congress
click the link
we've also just published a special
report I wrote about China's Ambitions
for the world order and you'll find a
link to that in the description below
and don't forget to subscribe